[Music]
hello I'm back again with another
episode of that still unnamed serious
about historical figures and books and
whatnot
in fact since there seems to be people
actually watching these videos if you
have any suggestions for names or
subjects that you would like to know
more about just let me know in the
comments and I'll certainly I'll
certainly consider it this time we're
again dealing to some degree with a book
but mostly with a person and again we
are dealing with a Muslim philosopher
and historian and this is a person that
is a bit more well-known that had been
to violence and and and also one that is
often considered to be the father of by
some people at least the father of the
science of history sociology and in some
cases even economics
his name was eben Hal doom and he wrote
this amazing piece of work called the
mock edema or introduction to history
and this is not just some metaphorical
or cryptic title it literally is the
introductory chapter to a much larger
piece of work called the kitab al-abaad
or book of lessons which is this
enormous collection of that aim to bring
together or sort of give a general
overview of history and civilization in
general you know Kadima has been an miss
to this day however still considered a
separate piece of work that has had a
great influence on on both the scientist
at the science of history and sociology
eben Halden was a philosopher and
historian who was born in Tunis in what
is today Tunisia and would later go on
to become one of the most famous and
revered figures in Muslim history and
now the context in which he lived is of
course incredibly important as it always
is in understanding him or his work in a
proper way he he lived in what is known
as the medieval period of the Muslim
world the Abbasid Caliphate which is
sometimes referred to as the Classical
period ruled much of the larger Islamic
Muslim world at least symbolically from
around 750 ad to 1258 when as you
probably know that the Mongols in their
campaign to to conquer the entire
goddamn world eventually reached Baghdad
and thus also executed the last
remaining Calif and this was obviously
very traumatic for the Muslims as their
sort of main seed of power and the
symbol of the grand
Islamic civilization had just vanished
and and so even held on finds himself
right in the middle of this sort of
trauma and this very uncertain period in
Islamic history referred to as the
medieval period which is after the fall
of the ax Bassets but before the
eventual rise of the Ottoman Empire and
I mean how the one is perfectly placed
right in between these when these sort
of Islamic world was very fragmented and
ruled by a whole bunch of different
regional smaller kingdoms and Sultan's
even Halden then was was born in 1332
like I said in Tunis and he came from a
long lineage of statesmen and
politicians from al-andalus
Andalusian Spain his father though was a
renowned Sufi of the time who who when
even Halden grew up would teach him a
lot about his own mysticism and the Sufi
tradition on top of this had been held
on had a lot of other teachers whom he
writes very highly and fondly
about his education with these teachers
included everything from Sufism to
philosophy and the Quran as well as
mathematics logics
astronomy you know all these things it's
safe to say that if Alduin was a rather
tightly that was highly educated man
both in the Islamic and also the
so-called worldly sciences his early
life appeared to have been rather
peaceful as he spent his time in
intellectual discovery and education but
a turning point in his life came when
the plague struck Tunis in the North
Africa yes the plague was obviously not
something that just affected Europe but
the entire world and and once the plague
actually arrived in North Africa and in
Tunis it wiped out amid Halden's entire
family basically as except for a few
siblings and his teachers and and he
writes himself about this event in very
sort of apocalyptic ways and I yes I
need these glasses are now because I'm
gonna quote him quote in the middle of
the 14th century civilization both in
the East and the West was visited by a
destructive plague which devastated
nations and cost populations to vanish
he continues cities and buildings were
laid waste roads and science were
obliterated settlements and mansions
became empty dynasties and tribes grew
weak the entire inhabited world changed
it was and here even Halden evokes a
very sort of poetic and and yet
apocalyptic language it was as if the
voice of existence in the world had
called out for Oblivion and restriction
and the world had responded to its call
obviously this events affected women
Halden
immensely and and had a very strong
impact on his life however it does
appear that it also served as a kind of
inspiration for his later career as
since the world had been so changed
there was a need for him to write
critically about history and in society
even Hardin was a very ambitious man and
and and like from directly out of a
Hollywood film he is stuck in his early
working years with a job that he hates
as a calligrapher and sort of dreams
about better things to come and they
certainly would come because he would
leave eventually and go on to become one
of the most successful political
advisors of his time and indeed of all
time he traveled all around North Africa
working for different Sultan's and Kings
he worked for a while in Morocco and
then he was in Algeria and even for a
while he worked in Granada in Spain and
Andalusia while working for these
Sultan's and kings and rulers he he came
to realize how filled with jealousy and
and corruption the political world
actually was rulers rose and fell in
what appeared to be very short spans of
time the whole thing was just very
chaotic he was himself the victim of
jealousy and some nasty schemes that at
some points even put him in jail but he
was not entirely innocent himself in
fact I mean Kowloon was obviously a very
intelligent and knowledgeable man and he
used that knowledge to his advantage for
example if a sultan if he felt like a
sultan or a king he worked for his time
was running out he would often support
the rebels unbeknownst of these Sultan's
so he would betray him basically because
of its knowledge of the political world
and how it worked he could sense that
that that the Kings time was over and in
most cases he was actually correct even
though even Hal Doan appears to have
eventually felt the kind of de stayin
towards the political world that he
worked in he was nonetheless incredibly
successful throughout his life and every
ruler basically wanted to work with him
or have him by their side even the
Christian King Pedro of Sevilla asked
him to join him to which he refused for
reasons that are not entirely known or
low some can make educated guesses as to
why you really start to feel for the guy
as he just wants to sort of retire and
go live in seclusion with his family and
writing and then teach but you know
different
rulers are constantly just dragging him
back into service because he is so
revered as this incredible political
figure or this thinker it's almost like
in the scene in The Godfather Part three
where where Michael is you know during
that famous line of you know once I
thought I was out they pull me back in
it's it's just really just like that and
you really feel sorry for him is he kind
of at multiple times in his life
actually does withdraw but is pulled
back into service by different Sultan's
to his sort of disdain the last years of
his life he spent in Mamluk Egypt in
Cairo as a kadhi or a judge he was
actually the main representative of the
Maliki School of Law in an islamic
sharia for the sultan but cook who ruled
at the time he seemed to have been at
this time actually rather content with
his life he enjoyed his time in egypt
and he there is some very poetic letters
that he sends to his friends about cairo
and how magnificent this city is however
there is you know even in Cairo one does
not escape the political corruption that
he is dealt with his entire life and he
becomes almost like a Serpico figure of
his time I realized there's a lot of
references to Al Pacino films in this
video but in any case it kind of fits
because he would refuse to succumb to
this corruption himself and would
actively fight against it which like in
the film created a lot of enemies except
for the Sultan himself actually he
appears to have stuck with him at least
for the majority of his time and service
his happiness in peaceful life was
unfortunately cut short however when
most of his family including his wife
and and some of his children were
tragically killed in a accident at sea
they had been separated for quite a
while when when even Halden moved to
Egypt and they were finally going to
meet at last again and on the way there
they were tragically killed which sent
even Halden into a devastating
depression - which took quite a while
for him to recover and this is very
humanizing to read - really puts things
into perspective and makes us see the
man behind the works as it were sort of
start to see him as a person rather than
this legendary figure that he is often
presented as he was eventually able to
get out of this depression and he
continued to work as a teacher in Cairo
and even there were some periods of
tensions between him and the the the
Sultan which I unfortunately did not
have time to go into but generally he
and the Sultan appears to have had a
good relationship throughout his later
years and career and he worked as a
teacher at a Sufi shrine I believe I
mean Calderone eventually passes away on
March 17th 1406 having spent his life in
service of a multitude of different
Sultan's and Kings and through his
writings and teachings have cemented
himself in the history books now
throughout the years of service and his
impeccable experience and and close-up
view of the political and social world
and Muldoon was obviously able to gain a
great understanding of how these worlds
actually works this would all be
expressed in the mock oedema and
inspired a lot of its genius really
[Music]
as mentioned the maca Deena is just the
introductory chapter to a much larger
piece of work but it it certainly stands
on its own in the book urban Halden
really tries to give a comprehensive
overview of civilization and culture and
politics in general it is considered a a
masterpiece that has not only had a
great influence on ottoman society but
also the rest of the world and still to
some degree today even Halloween is
considered in fact by some to be the
father of the science of history and the
study of sociology and as it is in this
book that he expresses a lot of those
ideas in the MOCA demon condom presents
a view of history that is completely
unique for his time he simply doesn't
want to retell things not history just
as a retelling of events but to actually
study history critically and to look at
things from a rational point of view and
try to explain them and it's in a sort
of a larger scientific context now while
the mock oedema is a say large piece of
work in itself with a lot of content
that I really don't have the time to go
through today I can talk about one of
these central aspects of his political
theory which is something that he calls
a Subbiah
and it's always difficult to translate
Arabic to English but it is generally
believed to mean something along the
lines of tribal solidarity at this time
when he lived and still to this day to
some degree Arab and Berber society is
very much divided into different tribes
and all political and social workings
are based on solidarity and
identification with these different
tribes in fact even Harlan considers a
Subbiah
to be the very driving force behind all
of history
he argues that dynasties and empires all
dynasties and empires are destined to go
down the same path one of rise and
eventual fall this is unavoidable
without question every dynasty
faul every single time and he uses a
Subbiah to explain this when a ruler
comes into power he does so with the
help of a Sevilla tribal solidarity with
the help of one or multiple tribes that
was that's he sometimes also belonged to
and their political supports other
factors such as divine or religious
motivations or inspirations that it can
be important as well but he argues that
that a Subbiah is the is the sort of
most important in fact he writes in a
very blunt way and says that power does
not exist without a Subbiah
period now after this he argues to sort
of delve deeper into this theory that
every dynasty rises and falls but it
goes through certain stages which he
refers to as generations these can be
different according to you know
circumstances but generally he says it
doesn't last for more than three
generations and the first generation is
is good the first generation of rulers
that is good he the king in this case is
still strongly connected to a Subbiah
he still remembers how tribal life
looked like and he still serves the
people in that sense he is connected to
the social world and reality the second
generation is somewhere in between he
still has some memories of the tribal
life that his father lived for example
but he has started to adopt some luxury
and access and stuff like that so he's
he's in between it still works but it's
it's it's starting to it's started to go
in the in the wrong direction and now
the third generation is where all falls
apart at this point the ruler is so
obsessed with luxury and access sort of
excessive living that he has lost all
connection to a Subbiah and thus also
the support of the people his main
concern is to stay in power and not to
serve the people and thus he has been
completely
from reality and when this happens this
is where the fall happens so at this
point another ruler with very sort of a
Subbiah and their tribal support takes
over and thus these cycles sort of
repeats indefinitely forever in other
words it is through a gradual loss of
tribal a Subbiah that that rulers lose
their power and eventually fall it's
certainly an interesting theory to
consider it's hard to deny that but
every dynasty and Empire at least so far
in history has fallen and nothing has
lasted forever now I've been held on
here presents us with a theory an idea
of why this is the reasons for this
inevitable rise and fall of every Empire
and every dynasty and it is through
ideas like this that he has really
cemented himself as an incredibly
important writer and influential thinker
now there are of course some other areas
of the book where it certainly shows his
age and this is another point to where
his context really need to be considered
there is for example a section that
describes black Africans and a rather
unfortunate way and in this section he's
trying to sort of correlate what he
calls the great emotionalism of the
African population with the hot climate
in which they live and sort of compares
this to drunkenness when drinking wine
because the body gets hot when you drink
it's it's really it's it's a mess now
this is obviously ridiculous and not
just slightly racist but it serves as an
important reminder that we cannot
separate him despite his genius in some
areas we cannot separate him from his
time and place and to consider when held
awareness somehow my modern thinker
stuck in an unenlightened age is is
highly problematic and dangerous this
not only presents a a dangerous view of
history that put things out of context
but it also undermines the achievements
of the medieval Muslim world you and I
been hollowness somehow separated from
his
in place and his culture and put in some
kind of modern narrative paints a
picture that the time in which he lived
was indeed unenlightened or were sort of
intellectually lacking which is simply
just not true nonetheless I mean Harlan
is a very important and interesting
figure that deserves a lot more time
than this to go through properly but I
hope you have at least enjoyed this
short dive into his world and his works
I may not be the most frequent uploader
on this here YouTube but if you do have
any suggestions for future episodes or
ideas then I would love to hear them so
just leave them in a comment or
something in any case I do have some
ideas myself so there probably be some
future videos that I have planned thank
you for listening
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]